I gotta say I heard your character might
have a new love interest this season so
keeping it sexy I mean you gotta always
keep should always be sexy I mean this
season ups the ante right I've heard
darker also funnier intense what was it
like for you and what can we expect um
it was a little bit of a wild-card for
me actually because you know I think
while we were season 1 we had a book to
base the entire season off in season 2
we had a novella it was a little bit
different and I think you know we were
all trying to figure out our characters
as we were going and so she Jane's
character II really wanted to pay homage
to what healing can look like
post-trauma not to ever take away the
experience that she endured but what is
how does she move forward in a way that
provides more lightness to her own ass
than her own journey and so that's what
felt a little bit like a magic 8-ball
you know I didn't really know exactly
how it was gonna end but I'm really so
happy and so grateful but though
everything is unfolded and and one thing
unfolded in a big way Meryl Streep
joined the cast
oh yeah there's her that person but I
mean you have some scenes with her right
what was it like working with Meryl I
mean look Merrill's in incredible humans
she's in a strong vulnerable kind
empathetic compassionate generous woman
and so separate you know from her just
being an actress and then you talk about
her as an actor and there's a reason why
she's Meryl Streep there's a reason why
people make up face when they say her
name and why I make that based on their
name it's because she really has worked
your entire life of perfecting her craft
this is a crafts woman and her skill is
to be an amateur well and I mean can I
ask you when you met her what do you say
that first time
and you don't really have to say
anything because she I think the knows
immediately that everybody has a
pretense for like I'm about to meet
Meryl Streep and she immediately disarms
you with her generosity and her smile
and her more that you almost in a way
feel like there isn't there's no wall
there's no in-between you kind of forget
for a minute that she is the amazing
actress that she is and you just get to
know her on a human level and that's
that's really her superpower is being
able to just be real in every every
single moment heard she also shared a
couple glasses of wine with you have one
gotta get the wine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]